hey bros before this video begins I just
want to take a quick moment to say thank
you to brain blasts Gamescom they
donated fifty thousand for the charity
that we did and I just wanted to extend
another big big THANK YOU to them
I live in link to them in description
and you can check them out enjoy the
video
granny get on top of the boat hang on
hang on granny is crazy let me get on
top granny loves it on top Oh calm down
ready driver stop please yeah we're not
even in trouble for this [ __ ] we're
hostages here granny where'd you go oh
you falling on some stairs the
background yeah just set in the back
ready
Oh ready got [ __ ] a granny Santa closer
for bread
granny granny you look good granny
that's a nice granny ass right there
why does granny look like she has rabies
[ __ ] hell could I offer you keep
shooting got ya limp Biskit tooth will
swindle my bed stop running into the
flames you [ __ ] idiot okay granny
granny can you finally defeat me near
defeat you ready now can you remove it
the power did you finally defeat me
you have are the power it has been only
one
ready I'll never die I live it
your soul is granny's want to quickly
hit this ball ready give it and
carefully mr. tip ready to sneeze threat
to Ted a caliph Ted breaks off of her
[ __ ] knife and then she'll go and
start I am [ __ ] already but the smell
is freaking the [ __ ] I'm feeling my face
only out of letting ran out of there
with the [ __ ] Rani fifty only gets it
down I got less because I'm a woman
so the end nothing to do with your
womanhood granny it's because you're old
and you called a shoe anyway so you
don't be the boy cheese granny yes
is there some reason we're in England oh
yeah granny you like that like this
let's rock
like I've seen this on the internet
somewhere this is the next 50 shades of
grey don't worry yourself in the glass
hahaha what if Isis goes there really
did you find lit me up
[ __ ] yeah great birthday smell my finger
even greater smell my finger please no
no no my finger granny it's been in your
[ __ ]
please smell it smells funny shut much
manmohan smelling this one smells like
dead cats granny you gotta check this
[ __ ] out man she's just a nervous twitch
I have been talking to women
oh thank you we should play hide and
seek
okay go I'll go stay in the corner yeah
all right when I count to 21
Oh God Blackburn what are you doing
Harry four five [ __ ] 600 eight nine ten
I can't go count to ten hey you're not
here I came and then where could felix
be mm-hmm if you hear the shower running
that's essica coincidence
yes ha ha
here ready or not here our librarian
jesus [ __ ] christ
get a job librarian hey I can't see him
I've looked everywhere where is he I
hear him laughing what do you [ __ ] it
sounds like it's coming from me right
here from right here this point right
here I hear him say get an oh my god oh
yeah I got one ha ha
stasis crises getting [ __ ] out of me
granny oh darling I'm not gonna die here
gray silly now come on
them young I need to live you're old and
disgusting oh mama now MA
all right ready
you win but you go first [ __ ] all right
okay try to land in this you gotta try
to land in this uh this red laughing it
no that's all me I'm no about them Oh
hungry whenever you're ready I'll push
her off I think we're ready
really where's the fountain hang on let
me see with the phone in it
okay I can't [ __ ] see with the phone
don't move more [ __ ] sake oh man this
is so bright I can't all right I'm in
first person so prefer to improve it
granny you should look at me while I
just just show you - hang on hang on
hang on Han all right let's take our
punishment back man you were a shitty
grandmas oh man I suck so much I go I'm
sorry I'm sorry
I'll never die oh all right can you
should land the helicopter on top of the
truck ha ha shoot him get him oh oh yes
yes do this Saturnia
oh man that is good oh I'll help them
push it me that any dad oh oh oh Jesus
there's some explosions going on right
beside me Jesus all right stop oh boy oh
God oh we can sign on it
no and Brandi's grown up oh [ __ ]
all right where we going tennis to the
Jessica advice for the first court
tennis go boy wait we only new outfits
so when you white Oh do we need to go
get Oh what happened you know really
exploding someone knows fire was the
truck on fire when we done might have
been on fire [ __ ] it now okay I'll go
for careful not explode off okay get
some gases how we're doing yeah we're
gonna get some gas real quick
gas me up boys yeah you want to watch
granny walk away I want to direct we're
going to be granny wash the car
how do I my granny watch the car hold on
let me see if I can next time on beauty
are you ready okay I remember okay okay
right
I'm out how about jacks Amy we did it we
did it guys
we did it we did it laughs Brandi you're
the wrong side I can't get hurt
granny see now she doesn't know we're
just here to confuse now I got a gay the
cat agree I take the blue